uh knock knock
if i was on if i was not on cooldown
you'd be dead
just know that are you crying
five four got you
wait is that jack
he's trying to bribe the killer
hey what's up blue pews wait where are
you oh hey what's up
hey what's up what's up chill what's up
just chilling so everything's water into
the bridge now just making sure that
place doesn't
oh yeah yeah yeah for sure making sure
the place doesn't fall apart
me too just did some numbers oh numbers
that's great all the way up to 10.
you've been doing really good at numbers
lately thank you thank you
i [ __ ] up i'm so dumb you're
distracting me
stop talking no just kidding bottom left
top right middle top right bottom left
top right okay
top middle right okay okay all right did
it work
you've already searched a troll all
right let me be i'm just trying to help
you to learn it
better oh okay that makes sense i
appreciate that thanks
yeah yeah anything to you man i got you
all right well thanks for following me i
really appreciate that
i'm sure you'll protect me if anything
goes down right
oh it's corporate okay all right this
time
wait i gotta wait for it my bad and it
moves does it move
is that jack at the bed okay so what do
i have left
okay my last tasks are all here
oh hey what's great i knew you weren't
gonna die
hey man where'd she go oh hey how you
doing lately
yeah pretty good yeah cool
what's your favorite task uh the one in
balcony i'm gonna do that now actually
see ya
why did i tell him where i was going one
more
okay now we wait irish people look like
potatoes
they're all round and weird you only get
one dave
irish people suck
he doesn't need me irish people stink
yeah good job guys
good job guys good job
when he says his favorite episode of
happy with is episode 69.
it's good oh that's a classic i'm gonna
watch episode 16
okay it's me
all right who's who's imposter jayden
she has tiny legs she'll never catch up
on us
wheezing through the wall i was just
saying jaden will never catch us
that's true and if she goes we can
outwit her with our intelligence
with our smarter bigger brains i can't
even say brains from
brains we can actually try
here it's actually making it hard to do
the numbers wait wait wait
i actually can't hear it if i send
outside and you scream i can't really
hear it
go in the corner of the screen i want to
see how good it is
you're right i heard one ah how many
hours did you do
15. oh my god
dude we're safe this is easy okay yeah
why would we think of this
okay we'll do the last one in cafeteria
i want to see a stack of bodies here no
glare you're ratting out again
is she camping the hallway that's pretty
smart actually
she's camping the whole way isn't she
jaden are you camping
are you camping the hallway i am oh
that's [ __ ]
i can't go past you then you never know
when my cooldown is ready
uh i'll just i'll just wait here okay
yeah all right
i don't even no don't you can't leave
your spot you can't leave your spot then
someone might pass you
yeah you're right yeah well there's no
one down here i can tell you that
i can hear you just barely it's like
you're yelling down the hall
because i am yelling down
don't no don't do it all right well
you're cool then it's definitely ready
now
you can get a snack but that's not me
oh no what the [ __ ] are you doing
away from me swedish bad luck
she's camping
never see us here you think she sees our
names no she's blind
what is it actually harder here when i
whisper
a little bit okay um what's your
favorite asteroid
um then big one
you know i put you up for such a shitty
question
it's really my fault
i have all my tasks in the top area are
you done
oh i have to go to spawn and la or
reactor
well what the [ __ ] are you okay okay
okay one two three
i can hear you super well dude you're
echoing through the entire
planetarium or whatever it is it's cool
it's this is i'm doing a bit don't worry
oh sorry don't mean to incorrect here's
the bit i said what's she gonna do
kill me and then if she does kill me
that's like the perfect cutting point
you see okay so just keep saying that
until it happens
yeah yeah okay good
all right last task
last task this is it last task
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yes oh my god i was the last
hey where were you guys i couldn't find
it i was in the greenhouse
i was in the green i don't know how you
didn't hear him screaming
when you asked that he was there
i'm always the last one to do all the
tasks i keep thinking i do it but i
guess
i'm impostor you all get 10 seconds to
run away
thank you that's his impostor voice he's
very serious he's lying
don't trust a word guys i am not lying
i have never killed anybody
did he just run past me what the [ __ ] oh
you're alive what the [ __ ] he just came
oh run all right
jack you're dead
oh my god well well well
if it isn't mr swede that's me i'm the
only swede
oh everybody hold the door close on me
hello everybody
get away from me
what are you doing hello everybody i'm
here
joe one of us is gonna have to run for
it okay
hello everybody you distract him
you're gonna have to take one for the
team you understand
someone's gonna have to sacrifice
welcome to the hallway of death who's
around here oh
dude i've done this [ __ ] thing three
times let me just do it and then you can
kill me all right
you slam something dude that sounds like
a broken keyboard
all right turn up no it's very sturdy
all right
go honestly i've not even killed you i
don't remember
that was it here is it middle wait chat
was it metal why am i distracting you
oh sorry oh you're really focused you're
gonna
just kill me you kill me please i don't
want to do this just kill me okay
that's hilarious
is there anything more fun than doing
simon says it's left left
right i did it
i did it i did it yeah
i still have all my tasks i'm starting
to see why i'm always the last one now
all right this is the last one are we
going to win now
for [ __ ] sake oh my god
felix always the last shut up
oh we won hey i'll take it
all right don't say who you are
beautiful noises
so if i find the imposter hypothetically
i don't say it now
do that one learn that on the recorder
honestly okay wait how do i play
with notes
like that
hey corpse i want to show you something
wait what do you want to show me
this way
you can be like a bod what are you going
party
he's here he's here guys
that's fine i'm enjoying this
you want to give it a shot everyone has
card swipe yeah um
you've you've really grown thank you oh
course he did
a harpsichord
this one's for you jack
i'll play that on his funeral i'm siren
head
this is your whole thing now i love it
please more music inspiration
oh no it's not copyrightable of course
no it's something else right
it's cafeteria still okay so two in med
bay let's get those
what's your favorite song i'll play it
for you
you got that
sorry but you gotta go man i'll play
i'll play the song of that
no dammit
don't
speaking in codes just cheating hey
let's
let's put some irish yes please the
password to call it somebody in ireland
is a good guy
yeah the good ones finish these lyrics
choke me like you lost me because you
love me
when you i love you corpse
i gotta wait i guess they didn't do it
right
does anyone know the lyrics quick
quick wait what did we get
what did he say
oh god it's so close
what happened here did you just did you
know that
i said i knew his lyrics and they were
all good and he left me alive
okay good good that's how we keep alive
gotcha
so you've got to go on his genius page
now make sure you memorize them
corbs genius make a sack pippa lap
got all these manchester
no face like it's no way
i could stop myself yeah he just asked
me the white t lyrics so you can't use
that song
okay uh uh thank you problem solver
well then you can roll the dice huh
philly pretty pen
up when i'm swerving through the night
uh got a million [ __ ]
and they trying to hit my line stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ]
finna sweat up switch up on a dime
with the cash where the women they all
can lose their mind
i just want some lawyer brothers making
money trying to grind but
yeah y'all just want to talk man oh i'm
doing it wrong voice that you think
something try so hard to find
uh keep playing pretend [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] what you want i
don't give a [ __ ] who you need
i actually haven't heard this song
you don't worry about that when you're
screaming in your room your neighbor's
just gonna get brilliant
i haven't really i have good neighbors
they're they're all right they know
my neighbors said that make
you should have changed him that's
garbage man
god god damn it you didn't spill the
wine on your dick what the
all right
so i learned the chorus and i'll do it
right now
okay here we go here we go turn them up
there you go excellent vocals actually
instrumental by felix thank you
thank you i was dancing you couldn't see
it but next time
whoever sucks gets to die
oh no what if so wherever it's imposter
is the judge right
okay okay show on town
so we have to plead for our lives
okay i am going to do my impression he's
prepping something this is going to be
good okay
okay here we go okay i've heard this a
lot but it's good okay
hey he's been put on the spot he's first
a guy
dude that's so like that was it
that's so like him do i live yeah yeah
you can live
you got it you got it jack all right
come on i'm also irish okay what
not real irish corpse ah all right yeah
it's just in my blood
okay no no no no no
okay here we go got a support got a
story story okay
an irishman goes to the doctor well
after
examining him says you have some
problems with your hair
but if you take these tablets i think it
will be okay so the doctor gives the man
the tablets and the patient asks
do i have to take them every day no
replace the time
take one on the monday skip the tuesday
take one on the wednesday
skip the thursday and go on like that
two weeks later the doctor is walking in
down the street and he sees the
patient's wife hello mrs murphy
just kill him just kill him
oh so what happened to this googling
aloud guys
okay okay all right definitely
you die if you google okay pj you're up
next
plagiarism immediately
okay let me know if you can hear this
this is this is one thing i got let me
know if you can hear that
i heard you say bobby baby bobby boopy
okay yep that's it
that's the that's the talent oh there's
nothing broken i didn't hear his
it do it voice more times better
ten more times okay you keep doing that
yeah
so he caught his turn i'm dario
i got love in my tummy
really far i'm just gonna go for it keep
going
what's that was that a lion and that's
what's gotten me this far
i mean that's pretty good i'm i'm kind
of simping yeah honestly it got me
through the round it should get him
through the road yep
thank you uh okay uh knock knock
how about this when i hear a bad cat
joke
just just kid then
i'm voting him no no no no no no no no
no no no
no that's that's not it's my fault
you're a cat you have to vote him
yeah that's right
that's my stuff man
oh no okay so who is going to be the
winner
on the skeleton honestly honestly
whoever's got the better corpse between
the two of you i think a rap battle
is in order a rap off like one of us has
an advantage here
so yeah you don't have to rhyme i'll
i'll i'll say you can have a rap battle
with that right it's a roast battle
okay i can't do this
i don't like
people them him out you're trying to
pick me against
corpse she's doing this it's the classic
corpse classic he always does this at
the end
of it because he saw me doing it
it was me i did all of it god damn
i feel like i made the most effort out
of there
at least
trying isn't worth it yes well done
looking for some high level gaming gear
check out face
okay but of what top scientists have
determined that wearing base gear makes
you a better gamer
with at least two percent basis for
everyone no matter what level you're at
but you need to be at least six eight to
order which i am
for you have before december 11th to
place your order
and solidify your place in the gaming
history booth
so what are you waiting for buff up your
wardrobe today and head over to base.gg
basil i'm 68 i swear
can i order